[Música]
hola y bienvenidos a europa hoy el
programa de actualidad europea de france
24 en español yo soy esther herrera caro
desde el parlamento europeo en bruselas
es un placer saludarles en el programa
de hoy analizaremos el impacto de este
año y medio de pandemia la campaña de
vacunación en la unión europea y la
desigualdad en el mundo cuando sólo el
2% de los países con menos ingresos han
recibido una dosis en europa hoy
resumimos que ha supuesto para el mundo
estos 18 meses desde que la cob y 19
cambió por completo la vida de todo el
planeta
la unión europea no quiere bajar la
guardia a pesar de tener el 70% de la
población vacunada aunque los 27 países
del bloque confían en que lo peor de la
pandemia ya pasó sobre todo en españa e
italia donde el kobe hizo estragos en la
primera ola aún se mantiene en alerta
porque los contagios que no desaparecen
se pueden incrementar de nuevo con la
llegada del invierno
las naciones del centro y del sur de
europa ya tienen más de la mitad de su
población inmunizada la región del este
más reticente con la vacunación apenas
alcanza un 50 por ciento en un intento
por crear más conciencia entre sus
ciudadanos la unión europea ha impuesto
medidas para influir en la decisión de
vacunarse exigiendo un pase sanitario ya
sea a prueba de vacunación o un test
negativo para ingresar a los lugares
públicos como bares y restaurantes
bélgica francia italia españa alemania y
austria se cuentan entre quienes han
impuesto como obligatoria esta medida
mientras se pretende convencer al cien
por ciento de los ciudadanos de ponerse
las dos dosis muchos de estos países del
bloque ya se están planteando aplicar la
tercera tras la luz verde que ha dado la
agencia europea del medicamento la
decisión de europa de ir adelante con
las dosis de refuerzo va en contra de la
solicitud que ha hecho el director
general de la omct edrosa adhanom quien
pidió que antes de iniciar una tercera
inmunización en países ricos se debería
terminar de vacunar a las personas de
naciones con menos recursos
para analizar todas estas cuestiones nos
acompañan la sagra diputadas soraya
rodríguez del grupo renovar europa del
parlamento europeo y de unos montserrat
del partido popular europeo líder de los
populares españoles ambas miembros de la
comisión de sanidad de la eurocámara con
una amplia experiencia en gestión y que
han seguido muy de cerca todo lo que
conlleva la lucha contra la pandemia
bienvenida a soraya de los soraya
primero de todo empezamos contigo se ha
superado ya el 70% de vacunación pero
han pasado 18 meses desde que desde que
empezó la pandemia se saldrá de ella
volveremos a la vida de antes y hay que
convivir con este virus bueno lo que
está claro es que en estos 18 meses
hemos conseguido una vacuna y el 70 por
ciento de la población europea está
vacunada y vamos a seguir vacunando para
lograr el máximo de población más de un
90% de población europea vacunada creo
que nos acercaría ya a una situación de
cuasi normalidad
y todavía se nos abren muchas incógnitas
en el mundo y también en europa primero
como acabas de señalar hay mucha
población en el mundo que no está
vacunada que no ha recibido ni una
primera ni una segunda dosis y estamos
hablando de una pandemia mundial por lo
tanto la capacidad también de mutación
de este virus es enorme yo siempre digo
que el virus no quiere matarnos el virus
quiere sobrevivir cuando tenemos a la
mayoría de la población en el mundo sin
estar inmunizadas sus capacidades de
mutación son mayores por lo tanto esas
variantes del virus efectivamente están
ahí son una amenaza y luego hay que
tener en cuenta que también en la unión
europea'
nuestra el número de la población
vacunada es muy dispar más del 70 por
ciento de la media europea pero por
ejemplo en bulgaria sólo el 22,3 por
ciento de la población o en rumanía
estamos hablando de un porcentaje por
debajo del 35% que quiero decir con esto
quiero decir que tenemos que ser
prudentes
tenemos necesidad y lo estamos haciendo
de encontrar espacios de normalidad lo
estamos haciendo gracias a la vacuna la
vacuna es absolutamente necesaria para
hacer frente a esta crisis pero tenemos
que seguir sabiendo que hay incógnitas y
tenemos también que mantener medidas de
precaución distancia de seguridad
mascarilla en lugares públicos nuestro
comportamiento también va a determinar
si efectivamente para la primavera del
2022 podemos estar hablando ya de una
total normalidad justamente como
apuntaba a soraya y algunos países
europeos en que hay un porcentaje mínimo
de vacunación la presencia de la
comisión europea ursula von der leyen
alertó de una de una epidemia de los no
vacunados en su último discurso del
estado de la unión vamos a deshacer
comentó pero sobre todo yo añadiría de
lo que ha dicho más ahora ya es el que
viene para quedarse ahí yo me atrevo a
decir que un poco como la gripe la gripe
inicio el principio del siglo pasado y
hoy estamos vacunando pues sobre todo
únicos a personas vulnerables a los
profesionales sanitarios cada septiembre
octubre noviembre y diciembre hacemos
las campañas en todos los estados
miembros sobre la gripe por tanto la cob
it que viene para quedarse y por antes
que tenemos que hacer primero hemos
hecho una gran respuesta desde la unión
europea desde el parlamento donde hemos
conocido tres grandes cosas primero
investigar en una vacuna 2 invertir en
esa vacuna y por tanto conseguir esta
vacunación masiva donde estamos en estas
rachas de un 70 por ciento 3 hemos sido
solidarios con el resto del mundo hoy
podemos decir que han salido de europa
700 millones de vacunas al resto del
mundo son las mismas cantidades de
vacunas que han sido inoculadas en
europa por tanto las mismas que los
europeos han recibido son la misma
cantidad que europa ha exportado desde
ese también instrumento kóvacs y cuarto
importantísimo tenemos que trabajar para
que en el futuro cuando venga otra
pandemia estar preparados o si el commit
viene para quedarse mucho tiempo también
que estemos preparados por ello desde el
parlamento europeo hemos empujado esta
gran iniciativa que es la unión europea
para la salud de la misma manera que
tenemos la unión europea para la
libertad de movimientos la moneda única
tenemos pues la unión financiera
bancaria tenemos lo que nos ha enseñado
el comida todas las instituciones
europeas es que tenemos que trabajar
para la unión europea para la salud para
que estemos preparados para que estemos
bien coordinados con todos los estados
miembros y para que lo que nos ha pasado
no nos vuelva a pasar y sobre todo yo
añadiría muy importante en estos gaps
que hay que decía también sólo hay en
algunos estados miembros respecto a
todos estados miembros tenemos que
luchar contra la desinformación contra
las famous yo creo que ahí quizás no
hemos dado suficiente la batalla desde
las instituciones europeas para trabajar
contra las etnias europa ha basado todo
en la base de la evidencia científica y
así tiene que ser tanto desde la ema
como desde la del isi disi pero quizás
no hemos hecho suficiente esfuerzo en
combatir desde todas las instituciones
europeas y también desde los dos
miembros las técnicas duras todas hecho
referencia al mecanismo kóvacs quería
hablar sobre sobre esta cuestión es una
buena iniciativa ese es una buena
iniciativa porque se han dado dosis pero
algunos países se están quejando de que
claro tienen que depender siempre de las
donaciones es este un buen sistema no
crea mayores desigualdades del que estos
países tengan que esperar siempre a la
buena voluntad del resto mira la
iniciativa kóvacs es una buena
iniciativa pero es una iniciativa
insuficiente la realidad nos lo está
demostrando
recientemente guterres en la asamblea
general de naciones unidas el secretario
general ha dicho claramente hemos
superado el test de la ciencia con esta
pandemia del cobi pero no hemos superado
el test de la ética a día de hoy cuando
ya disponemos de vacunas cuando además
sabemos que las vacunas son efectivas
son necesarias son el único camino de
salir de esta pandemia hay una cifra que
me parece nos dice muchísimo de cuál es
la situación en el mundo más de 5.200
millones de dosis de vacunas se han
puesto en el mundo pero el 70% de estos
5.000 millones 5200 millones de dosis
sólo se han puesto en 10 países el resto
el 30% en el resto del mundo por lo
tanto podemos decir que los países ricos
han puesto 65 veces más vacunas que los
países pobres es decir el gap la
inequidad que existe en el acceso a las
vacunas es enorme
desde luego no está o no es conforme a
la ética pero tampoco es conforme a la
ciencia porque la pandemia es global y
no ha dejado de ser la desde el momento
en el que descubrimos la vacuna por lo
tanto la campaña de vacunación tiene que
ser una campaña de vacunación mundial
espero que con esta última iniciativa
también liderada por eeuu y por la unión
europea podamos realmente alcanzar el
objetivo pero a día de hoy estamos lejos
necesitamos duplicar la producción de
vacunas de aquí al primer trimestre del
2022 si queremos realmente conseguir los
objetivos de que el 40 por ciento de la
población en el mundo esté vacunada y
para eso necesitamos
mayor presupuesto la unión europea ha
decidido aumentar en 1.200 millones su
aportación al programa kóvacs pero
necesitamos realmente también hablar de
establecer capacidades de fabricación de
vacunas en países por ejemplo en áfrica
áfrica tiene al 17 por ciento de la
población el 1 por ciento ciudad de
producción de vacunas justamente
exactamente está haciendo incidencia
sobre esta cuestión pero ya se está
hablando de tercera dosis se está
hablando ya no sólo a personas
inmunodeprimidas y ancianos sino también
a la población en general y aquí puede
haber un problema porque la omm se está
hablando de que haya una moratoria
si bueno yo creo que europa ha actuado
muy bien porque siempre lo ha pasado
todo en evidencias científicas y en
nuestras propias agencias desde la
agencia europea del medicamento desde el
isi disi donde nos hemos basado siempre
en evidencia científica ahora mismo la
ema y la isi disi están valorando la
poder poner la tercera dosis y si
primero empezamos por los sectores más
vulnerables por tanto pero por lo que
tenemos que hacer es aquello que nos
digan los científicos importante que no
que nos lo diga la ema y la isi disi
ellos lo están evaluando esperemos su
evaluación cuando la tenga más la
tengamos pues estemos preparados europa
y ya está preparada para en su compra
centralizada para una tercera dosis por
tanto una vez la evidencia científica
diga empecemos con una tercera dosis y
empecemos con los vulnerables la unión
europea se ha preparado ya en esa compra
centralizada para esa tercera dosis
luego importante y también con lo que
decía sobre todo en la parte de
solidaridad o sea no vamos a terminar de
combatir esta pandemia si realmente toda
la sociedad mundial estaba curada por
tanto europa no sólo ha participado en
cobán sino que también ha hecho este
equipo europa que es un equipo europa
que es eeuu juntamente con europa pues
puede pudiendo producir pues en un
continente como puede ser áfrica porque
yo pienso sinceramente que el problema
que la izquierda ha puesto encima de la
mesa de que si patente si no o si se
suspende la propiedad intelectual ahí no
está el problema y no está el cuello de
botella el cuello de botella real está
en la producción en la transparencia de
conocimiento
hacia esos países subdesarrollados y
vemos un ejemplo ya mí simple me gusta
explicaron desde el año 2015 trips está
exento para 46 países subdesarrollados
donde desde el año 2015 hasta el año
2030 pueden estos países
subdesarrollados producir medicinas y
vacunas con la excepción de
pero he rebasado no lo están produciendo
porque el problema es la falta de
conocimiento la falta de recursos
humanos la falta de talento la falta de
transferencia de conocimiento tanto por
ello es importante que europa haya
invertido también en este equipo europa
y que haya comprometido 3.000 millones
de euros en este equipo europa para
producir vacunas en estos países
subdesarrollados y ayudarles para que
ellos puedan producir y puedan vacunar a
su población perfecto pues muchísimas
gracias nosotros no tenemos que dejar
aquí soraya duros muchísimas gracias por
vuestro tiempo por estar en france 24 en
español nosotros nos vemos en el próximo
programa de europa hoy gracias por ver
france24 en español
[Música]